والمناطق الشماليه الغربيه ايضا ولكن
الضغط الان يتركز على المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه هذا مع الاشتباكات
في المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه من خان
يونس اذا ما زلنا بعد 120 يوما ورغم
الانسحابات المتكرره والمناورات البريه
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عده مناطق
من قطاع غزه نتحدث عن المناطق الشماليه من
القطاع بدرجه اساسيه محيط مدينه غزه
الانسحابات بدرجه اساسيه كانت من المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه غزه والمناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه ايضا والمناطق الشماليه
بطبيعه الحال ولكن هناك ضغط كبير في
المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه لمدينه غزه
دعونا ندخل اكثر بتفاصيل اكثر لهذا المشهد
الميداني بمجموعه من المعلومات المهمه يوم
امس قتاه القسام كانت قد اعلنت بانها
استهدفت الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
الجنوبيه منذ عده اسابيع في هذه المنطقه
في هذا القاطع بهذا الشكل يفصل عبر وادي
غزه يفصل مدن مدن واحياء المناطق الشماليه
من قطاع غزه عن المناطق الجنوبيه ويكثف
عملياته خلال الايام الماضيه بهذا الشكل
باتجاه تل الهواء بصوره اقرب لما يحدث في
تل الهواء فان المشهد يدور الان في هذا
المربع الصغير للغايه كتاب القسام اعلنت
يوم امس عن قنص 15 جنديا اسرائيليا في هذا
المربع مربع الجوازات وايضا استهداف عدد
من ناقلات الجند والدبابات في هذه المنطقه
منطقه الجامعات اذا ما تحدثنا ورسمنا
خارطه او شكل لما يحدث هنا فنحن نتحدث عن
هذا المستطيل الصغير الذي قد يبدو كبيرا
على الخريطه ولكنه لا يتجاوز بهذا الشكل
كيلو و300 متر في اقصى حد ولا يتجاوز بهذا
الشكل 500 متر اذا نحن نتحدث عن مساحه
بسيطه للغايه ولكنها كثيفه العمليات
العسكريه سواء لكتاب القسام وسرايا القدس
من جهه او لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي
قلنا بانه يشن عملياته من جهه شارع 10ش
باتجاه منطقه تل الهواء ويركز على المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه رغم انه كان قد انسحب
منها خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
الانسحابات يوم امس تركزت لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
كما ذكرنا من منطقه العطاطه الشيخ رضوان
في هذه الاحياء انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه
التي كانت قد تمركزت لعده اسابيع من بدايه
التوغل البري في الايام الاخيره من شهر
اكتوبر تحديدا ال7 او 28 من اكتوبر توغلت
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وتمركزت في
هذه النقطه واتخذت من هذه النقطه منطلق
عملياتها للضغط على الاحياء الشماليه
والاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه غزه بهذه الشكل
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن ما
زلنا نستمع عن بعض المعلومات التي ترد
بشان اصابات او استشهاد فلسطينيين في هذه
المناطق هذا يعني ان اما ان هناك بعض جيوب
لقوات الاحتلال ما زالت مختبئه في هذه
المناطق او ان المسيرات الاسرائيليه لا
تزال تقوم بعملها وترصد الناس بشكل كثيف
نعود سريعا سريعا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا خانيونس خانيونس تشهد عمليات
عسكريه عنيفه في المنطقه الغربيه من
خانيونس بدرجه اساسيه منطقه حي الامل كما
اعلنت سياره القدس وكتائب القسام انها
ترصد التحركات الاسرائيليه في هذه المنطقه
هذا هو حي الامل الذي يضم مستشفى الامل
وفيه تشن القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول الضغط
على حي الامل لتصل الى هذه المنطقه من وسط
خانيونس لكنها حتى هذه اللحظه لم تستطع
ولم تتمكن من ذلك لان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لا تزال تشن عمليات دفع باتجاه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة